[Musique]
c'est avec fierté que la 17e promotion
de l' académie des dalons du bernica a
présenté son projet collectif monnières
a eu la chance de faire partie de cette
belle aventure qui lui permet
aujourd'hui d'envisager un vrai projet
d'avenir
je remercie un poids l'équipe des mets
se calmer grâce à et aujourd'hui j'ai la
confiance n'est pas moi et aussi j'aime
bien ce que nous a appris la façon
durable et voilà et de respect aussi
emma ça m'a fait du bien et du coup
aussi
c' est qu' à tracer mon chemin
c est qui m'a oublié mesure les tenants
du restaurant c'est moi qui dois finir
notre cour pays l'aménagement d'un
jardin pédagogique où se côtoient à quoi
ni apiculture ou encore lombriculture
c'est la création d'un jardin
pédagogique desjardins pays à l'académie
ballon c'était aussi un des objectifs du
projet lorsqu'il a été présenté il ya
six ans et
au fil des années on à améliorer
l'existant et là on a vraiment cette
année on s'est concentré sur l'espace de
l'académie avec toujours le souci de le
travailler avec d'autres et avec
l'objectif de pouvoir en faire un
véritable lieu de découverte pédagogique
pour les enfants les adultes les
services les écoles tout le monde sera
le bienvenu l' académie des dalons un
dispositif mis en place par le
département qui a pour but d'aider les
jeunes en perte de repères pour la
conseillère départementale jacqueline
henry
une belle initiative en direction de
notre jeunesse est une victoire pour les
éducateurs bien sûr et nous aussi
départements qui ont qui les ont
soutenus depuis le début c'est très
émouvant de les entendre dire que
aujourd'hui s'ils peuvent s'exprimer si
les ils ont pris confiance en eux c'est
grâce à l' académie des dalons la merci
opposition aux l'académie des dalons
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]